[Musique]
une stèle dans ce parc et des plaque à
la mémoire des victimes
dans chacun des lieux touchés les
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 sont à
jamais gravé dans l'histoire de france
[Musique]
un récent sondage indique même qu aux
yeux des français
c'est l'événement le plus marquant
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale et
pour cause il est 21h disserte ce
vendredi 13 lorsque des explosions se
font entendre devant le stade de france
pendant un match de soccer france
allemagne deux kamikazes viennent de
déclencher leurs ceintures d'explosifs
[Musique]
aussitôt après d'autres terroristes
armés de fusils d'assaut ouvrent le feu
sur les terrasses de six bars et
restaurants des 10e et 11e
arrondissement de paris comme ici à la
bonne bière
c'est impossible
enfin dans un groupe d'assaillants prend
pour cible le bataclan une salle de
concert où se produit le groupe
américain igor the terminator devant
plus de 1000 spectateurs
le bilan est terrible 130 morts et plus
de 350 blessés
à ce jour deux mille cinq cent soixante
dix-neuf victimes et proches des
victimes ont été indemnisées
coût total 64 millions d'euros soit près
de 100 millions de dollars
les deux années qui ont suivi ont été
marqués par toute une série d'attentats
meurtriers
près d'une vingtaine d' attaque au total
qui ont fait 92 morts et 4 175 blessés
la lutte contre le terrorisme a poussé
les autorités françaises a décrété
l'état d'urgence a mobilisé policiers de
gendarmes ainsi que dix mille soldats
dans le cadre de l'opération sentinelle
tous les lieux touristiques sont
protégés ainsi que tous les lieux de
culte
les gouvernements ont fait voter de loi
antiterroriste avant de finalement
mettre un terme à l'état d'urgence
il y a quelques semaines et le nouveau
président emmanuel macron a promis
d'embaucher lui dix mille nouveaux
policiers
mais la menace terroriste est toujours
très présente
les autorités disent avoir déjoué 32
attentat depuis le 13 novembre 2015 et
les services de renseignements sur 20
est activement 12000 personnes
radicaliser soupçonné de représenter un
risque pour la sécurité
deux ans après les attentats du 13
novembre les bars et les restaurants
touchés ont tous couverts
le bataclan lui a été le dernier à le
faire près d'un an après le drame
mais le café du bataclan lui est
toujours fermé et la fréquentation n'a
jamais retrouvé le niveau d'avant les
attentats
de toute évidence le 13 novembre 2015
restera pour longtemps encore une date
noire dans l'histoire de france
[Musique]